hey guys I'm Jess McDonald eat is a sick
of februari amongst the can't end soon
enough because it's so damn hard to say
and you're watching games but you first
op Soni is out of the PC business having
sold via to Japan industrial partners
and 5000 people are being laid off
worldwide according to the latest
earnings report this move will allow
them to focus their efforts on mobile
products sony have also planned to
transition their TV business into a
wholly owned subsidiary in the move to
help enhance profits so the same reason
anyone does anything the restructuring
has inevitably ended up causing massive
layoffs 1500 of which are expected to
come from Japan and another 3,500
internationally is this madness or just
business let me know we've heard a bunch
of sonic related rumors lately but in
the hopes of not inundated you with
false information we haven't been
reporting on them today though it looks
like you will be able to look forward to
some new Sonic the interestingly named
sonic boom is set to be a new branch of
the sonic universe it's having a go with
the whole transmedia thing which
defiance tried to do but probably a
little more on the lighter side it'll
encompass the game which will be for Wii
U and 3ds a TV series and a range of
toys and usable either put you off or
evoke mild interest the characters have
also received creepy leg-lengthening
makers apart from their extended
extremities sonic has got himself a
little brown scarf which doesn't really
go with his coloring and tails has
utility belts on top of that knuckles
grew about three sizes so that happened
also a me looks like a me as a result of
the deals that happen between Sega and
Nintendo last year sonic broom will be
the last sonic game that comes
exclusively to Nintendo platforms
mechanically the game will integrate
exploration combat and a tethering
feature alongside the traditional sonic
speed mechanic at this point that we use
seems to be facilitating full player
cooperative play and
leave the 3ds version won't be a
straight thought if this news story
hasn't whetted your appetite you can
check out the announcement trailer
complete with colorful high jinks and so
some reason Skrillex on site now and
finally we've got some news on the pier
or exclusive the order 1886 and it's
related to multiplayer and frame rate
resolution buffs can rest easy since
this one is coming in 1080p although
it'll run 30 yes the game is said to be
a strictly single-player third-person
action-adventure according to dev ready
dawn in response to game out price to
the multiplayer lessness Judea founder
andreya berzina have said it's better to
do one thing well that a whole bunch
haha sounds fine by me but what do you
guys think of the game and were you
hoping for multiplayer you can let me
know your thoughts and feelings in the
comments down below or my Twitter where
and at justice done that's all I got for
you today but let you know what you
cared about and I'll be back tomorrow
with my weekly top five